I think the Institute was very very much
affected by what was going on in the
country and in the world around it and
this of course is referring to the
escalation of the Vietnam War the
introduction as it were and the use of
drugs marijuana LSD I think then of
course aside from the war there was
Martin Luther King Bobby Kennedy was
shot there were things happening outside
that to which we had really rather
strong reactions not only our student
body but certainly our faculty and as
far as the Vietnam War it became very
clear that there was a big division
among the faculty and I'm sure among the
students probably too but certainly
among the faculty as to where the
country should be what the school should
be doing
we had the November action days we had
the March on the what's now the Draper
lab all of these things really kept
things kind of very tense
part of the time mm-hmm and how you know
I noticed in your remarks you said that
what I thought was understatement you
said it was a time that was certainly
interesting and then you mentioned that
the students had had act actions had
begun in 1968 and you said by 1970 we
had a somewhat quieter time two years
must have been quite a long time in your
personal life
to have Delmon with all those issues at
home and must have been a tremendous
strain for Howard as president and for
you so how did can you do one talk a
little bit about well - personal impact
there was some stranger we had three
let's see our youngest I think when we
moved in the president's house was 11
and so we had a active family with very
strong opinions as to what was going on
at the time of course the days were long
as far as as the president was concerned
but he had a wonderful group with whom
he worked the Academic Council was been
extremely supportive
they were quite well organized and in
very close contact all of the time it is
true you it was virtually a state of
emergency as I recall I mean you
remember it you were there - yeah and a
lot of the time of course there were
some some real crises when they took
over the president's office and a lot of
negotiations going on a lot of
negotiations for the city and the
protection of life and property and that
sort of thing then the Student Center
was occupied and that was a 24 hour a
day operation with people coming in from
all over and that was part of the
problem there were other college
students bust in came in the place was
wild mm-hm
I always remember when that student left
I went over to see what was left I was
particularly concerned about the floor
Vassallo Puerto Rico which is of course
where that student was and if you want
to say a little bit about the student so
that people will know what you're
referring to well this was an a WOL
marine and I
I really don't know how he actually got
to where he was I really don't know how
he was got to be sitting up in the
corner of that of the sour Perico but
after they had gone and I went over
there and I never saw so many pieces of
gum on the floor the floor was literally
littered with chewed gum that people had
parked and gotten tired of chewing of
course gum comes off I think fairly
easily yeah they had it cleaned up in a
hurry but there were well now now when
when the Institute was going through all
of this how did this affect I mean what
was your role do you think in relation
to the Institute and in relation to
Howard I mean were you directly involved
was your house under yes a couple of
times there was a pipe and they would
parade in front of the little circular
driveway in front of the president's
house so you actually had some concern
about the facility of yourself Campus
patrol there again campus Patrol had
someone watching the house really quite
carefully there was only one time that
we were told to leave the house and we
did and we went to a friend's house in
Brookline and stayed overnight we forgot
to take the cat that was the big crisis
we do our daughter's cat was very
distressed yeah how old were you kids at
the time they were set up your son well
they were in high school high school too
you know high it's going junior high
school mm-hmm how did they take all of
this mess si yeah they seemed to take it
in stride
they they survived you do they had
definite feelings particularly our
oldest who was in high school at that
time well when they look bad was
frightening well you know I don't
so no I don't believe so no mm-hmm and
then when you look back oh I wouldn't
want to do it again probably and I you
know you always think you could do
things better if you did him again but
yeah it was it was an ongoing thing I
always thought I should keep a diary of
some sort but and it's interesting to me
no one has really written up
what has times not just on this campus
but whether it's Michigan or whether it
was San Francisco Carnell I remember now
Cornell or whatever school to my
knowledge no one has has really felt
like sitting down and looking at it from
the perspective of either a student at
the times or the administration of the
school at that I think it's too painful
for people I wonder if it is if still
maybe too fresh for some you know it's
too searing that such memories did did
the did unit were universities in touch
with each other very much so I mean did
you talk to other wives for example yes
there is an association of I don't
recall how many universities that meet
annually and there are subcommittees the
wives go to the annual meeting and so we
did meet other lives at that time we met
in places like well Williamsburg for
instance one year which is an oasis for
everybody at the time right philosophers
away from your dad we did talk to each
other yes although not as an ongoing
thing you didn't just call up mrs.
Flemming at Michigan or something like
that and say well how are you today but
I know that that are my husband did talk
to presidents and others no because
there were other presidents whose
careers as presidents really ended
during that time because they had Lehman
Brewster talked to and also Nate Pusey
at Harvard sure they talked
right right without without it being too
just trying okay is there something else
yeah
no now when all of this was going on you
still had to be responsible for
organizing a lot of other things at MIT
probably and how did that how did you
manage what you construed as your other
responsibilities both for your family
and MIT as far as organizing things at
the Institute things were very much the
same the faculty wives met the
committees met the interest groups met
volunteerism went on the furniture
exchange functioned we weren't in any
sense in a state of paralysis or
anything like that we did what we had
been doing and what we continued to do
later wasn't changed do you want to talk
a little bit about some of the volunteer
activities that went on during that time
that it that interested you were there
particular matters that you were
involved with it that were particular
interest to you well the interest groups
were very much then the same I think as
they are now
I can't think of any that don't exist
and a few have been added and that was
always a pleasure we did our Christmas
decorating we had the bloodmobile we did
all of those things that we still do
today mm-hmm and what were were there
some particular activities that
interested you that you particularly
participated in during that period that
well I've been a birdwatcher for a lot
of years
Helen sizer was the one that started the
bird group and she should get a lot of
credit for it's still ongoing and very
very active and I enjoyed that but I
enjoyed the other things too did you
I've had a very left recollection that
you participated in some other Women's
League activity that it was the and
you're still a bird watcher I believe
you oh yes I do I'll tell a little bit
about well that's just simply a hobby of
power it's in mine yeah we go birding
yes the owl
yes the owl for several years right
outside these windows we had a barred
owl and it really helped take care of
the pigeon population it kept that down
considerably we are close enough of
course to Mount Auburn which is one of
the great birding spots so that an oasis
like our courtyard and our gardens and
so on and that's one thing that was a
part of the years in which we were here
this was the period in which we started
the pocket gardens in the different
little alcoves and places around the
Institute we had the Julie facet garden
and of course I was on the committee for
the fundraising for that and
a garden at Endicott House with benches
and a places for people to relax and it
was also during that period that they
they started adding about 1% of the cost
of a new building to be used for art in
the building and so when you look at our
brand-new biology lab which was just
dedicated last week and you have these
wonderful tile isn't that beautiful the
art in the different buildings around
the campus that permanent art collection
for these different buildings as well as
being built into the building was
started in Howard Johnson's
administration and I think it's added a
great deal in our campus in the
buildings I think many people would be
surprised at the transformation of this
campus from what it was in the early 60s
um of the alumni would notice a big
difference out do you want to talk a
little bit about what MIT looked like
when you got here what the difference is
that well if you look down the main
corridor I wouldn't say it looks too
different if you look around the edges
it's warmer it's softer I think and of
course it has I don't know how many new
buildings but a lot there was no art on
the campus and I think that well there
had been an art committee and then the
art council was started somewhere in
that period and of course is still very
much an ongoing active thing so they
work together pretty much and I trust
they still do well do you want to do you
have other high points that you'd like
to talk about during your career as wife
of the president well I think the role
of women was changing very
definitely it was during that time that
McCormick housed the second part of the
mccormick house was built
catherine mccormack was a very very
special person in what she left the
Institute being a fairly young
institution we didn't have lots of
historical things handed down through
the century sort of thing and she
endowed us with some very beautiful
china and glass and the contents of her
house over on Commonwealth Avenue and
this added many interesting things I
think to the president's house she left
it was the residue of her estate as you
know she was interested in the League of
Women Voters she was interested in birth
control she left a million dollars to
the ROC Institute which was doing
research on this is the pill and I think
during this period the pill became very
much into common more common usage than
it had ever been before and the access
to it
was quietly done and unobtrusively done
it was also during this period this time
that a really really conscious effort
was made to increase the rule the number
of women coming to this campus and of
course with McCormick Hall and the
second tower it really did give parents
and the students themselves a real place
to live and I can remember Margaret
Compton describing the living facilities
and in a house that something like
twelve women stood
lived in and Baystate road and that was
the housing for women at MIT it was it
was pretty grim you had to come here and
be prepared to live in town and make
your own way you had not really not a
comfortable organized place to be and
catherine mccormack made it possible to
have what we have today well we're just
very different now that you mentioned
Margaret Compton do you want to talk a
little bit about what your experience
was with the wives of the presidents who
proceeded well where there's mentors to
role models er as far as the wives and
the women at MIT course there were the
few outstanding ones like Ellen swallow
Richards and there were several others
but MIT and I have a picture a wonderful
picture which I know is in the archives
of Margaret Compton and Lou's Killian
and Kaye Stratton and myself and I I
don't think Leia was there at that point
Margaret was a wonderful person it was
an entirely different campus there
wasn't the traffic on Memorial Drive
she tells about an Irish Setter they had
that was all over the campus and and
just everybody knew that it was dr.
confidence Irish Setter
the the was it a female I don't know all
of the wives are very different people
we bring a lot of different things to to
the job in different times but I must
say we we like each other very much
and we enjoy being with each other and
now we're heard fewer of us because both
Liz and Margaret are gone would you like
to talk a little bit about how you see
the differences in the and the what you
brought to your roles
oh boy I gotta blow my nose got sinus as
soon as I start I had a hard act to
follow because I had to follow cased her
out and then that wasn't easy and she
was very very good Margaret had moved
off the campus and lived over on Beacon
Street at that time and I think during
the Depression I think money was very
hard to come by I think the budget was
slim tuition of course was much much
lower it was a different place in which
to live and I think it the whole
development of curriculum of more social
kind of a place all came during the
Stratton's and the Johnsons and kind of
has continued over the years as far as
the role as an individual I think the
first and foremost thing you want to do
is is help your husband in any way that
it looks like you could and we did do a
lot of entertaining I mean we serve
everything from breakfast to cut potato
cocktails to dinners and whatever and
those were planned and we had a staff at
that time and that took time we spent a
lot of time truthfully planning menus
and for various numbers of people and do
you want to talk a little bit more about
the what constitutes support of your
husband's in that role and how you felt
some of the other women carry I mean
there must have been big differences in
the way that operated for the wives do
you have I don't know I only know myself
no I'm not sure
there were I think that at that time in
your life that was where you were and
that was what you were doing and that
was what you concentrated on and in a
limited way I think that I can think of
two cases for a wife was not interested
in the school or in the being the
president's wife and doing whatever that
entailed and it it had a definite effect
I think it could I think it is important
and I suppose I say that partly because
if you're going to do it you need to
think it is important because that's
what you're doing at that time in your
life what was that in it I know that
case threatenin her remarks at the at
the luncheon mentioned that she and her
family she used the phrase moved into
the president's house with a great deal
of trepidation and felt that they had to
redefine their lives was that yes of
course that's true they we moved from
Lexington and into this house you know
we we had help as it were we had big
rooms instead of small rooms we'd meet
before dinner in the den and then
everybody would fan out to do their
homework and sort of disappear in this
big space so it is a question of keeping
together and and spending as much time
particularly on weekends just really
blocking out time for your private life
for your own private lives which if you
have family growing you must do and I
think maybe some people aren't doing it
as much now as they should do I don't
know from statistics that you read but
when you talk about you know the whole
notion of having to redefine your life
and think differently about it when you
were had you ever imagined that you
would be in such a role I mean what did
what had you thought about what were
your endeavor
I hadn't didn't you start out in music
yourself yes I do want to talk a little
bit about the evidence I know I didn't
follow through why I switched from music
and did some other work I did personnel
work uh-huh
but you hadn't imagined moving into the
oh no that of course was it I don't
think my husband ever really thought it
that he was going to do that either was
it something you a cognized about or it
seemed oh no no no no it wasn't a big
adjustment it was a big adjustment but
you did it if you remember that was that
yeah and in retrospect I must say it was
been a wonderful experience uh-huh do
you feel that that you've changed
considerably in the midst of that
experience that it was a big I mean in
learning to adapt to all they probably
did but I wasn't aware of it uh-huh you
you certainly did have to adapt
yes sure uh-huh because you owe us that
everyone talked about the the kinds of
people you were constantly in all these
wives
in their presentations that the luncheon
talked about the kinds of people you
dealt with and all with a bit of ah yes
and here you were meeting somebody but
it was it was fun it was you know and
and you're looking back on it you know
all you can say is it's been wonderful
you're just grateful you were there and
and and when it comes to what you I mean
if you want to talk a little bit more
you came when you came into this room
you talked about the furnishing of this
room what about converting that rather
uninspiring mansion into your family
home well the history of the house is
kind of interesting the stone Webster
was the Builder of of this the main
MIT campus on this side of the river and
they gave the president's house to the
Institute as a gift and as I understand
it it was their fee for having their
profit as it were from having built the
building and the architect was a man the
name Welles Bosworth and he designed
that house on the plan of a French town
house with a straight up and down facade
and back in front I'm sorry
a budding the street and then in the
back was the garden surrounded by wall
with a gazebo and so on and the rooms
are big the ceilings are high but there
is a little room off one of the main
rooms that we use kind of for our small
family gatherings and there was a little
room off the back kitchen where we had
breakfast and as a family with everybody
off to get their rides and their car
pools and whatnot and so you make your
space you make your space now as far as
the decorating of the house I'm sure
many people over the years have have
noticed a difference the furnishings in
the house get heavy use
I remember having the rug cleaned once
and after it looked I thought really
very nice and when the head man said you
know I've never seen a rug with so many
cigarette burns now you go to that house
today and there's not an ashtray in
sight and it's true
nobody smokes anymore in that house and
I and then there aren't signs up that
say no smoking it's just that the people
that go there do not smoke but it is the
privilege of the new person coming in to
redecorate the house and the timing has
always been such that in seven 10
whatever years intervening
it needs it it's things need to be
recovered and and much of that furniture
is shall we say recycled recovered and
fresh paint and that sort of thing and I
think probably everybody has used a
decorator you almost have to in that
you'd really don't have access to
fabrics and things that you need to do
it without going through a decorator you
need a professional
perhaps for ideas but certainly for
resource material and so on I almost
think you'd have to the dining room
table which is of course English and is
a very beautiful table
we bought because the Stratton's wanted
their table well actually it's here now
it's in the McLaurin room but we all
added something I guess in our way so
which stayed in some of which you asked
me what was the best thing and well I
think just being there just being a part
of a very active wonderful place lots of
things going on I think that probably
was the best part of being there just
being a part of it the word did you say
the worst thing the most difficult the
most difficult mm-hmm I don't know I
can't I I don't know what would have
been the most difficult that was it what
did for the times that you thought to
yourself well what am I going to do now
about something right oh I'm sure there
were yeah what what do it yes I'm sure
there were but mostly it was it was just
a wonderful place to be and to do and to
be a part of and when you look at your
own daughters or daughters-in-law or
your sons you know
the way women's lives have changed in
your comment earlier that it's important
to think about your role in relation to
your husband what's going to happen to
either men or women or when income
executives and don't have spouses who
are available like you were and it shows
to me well I have a daughter who's a
lawyer and I think she's she's probably
done things differently than I know she
has then I did at the same time but I
don't know quite how to answer that I
think there are so many things that come
into our lives not just your your mother
or your father but your school and your
friends and things that happen around
you that I guess it all adds up to what
that person does or doesn't do but it's
just as you said in your talk that the
world impacts on your life very
definitely and so I think it does you
know I mean do you think how do you you
could you visualize your daughter
filling the role that are one of your
sons perhaps filling the supportive role
that you saw as yours at the time not my
son's no no I don't think so I think
they're they're very much themselves and
I I don't think that I can see them
supporting somebody else in a role no I
I don't see it in my family now that
doesn't mean it couldn't happen in
somebody else's family right you said
you're mine do you see your daughters in
law or your daughter and that kind of
supportive role they'll play no my
daughter's I would say more dominant
mm-hmm so that sorts of real works very
hard in long hours and travels and no I
think she she does a lot and and when
you go back to thinking about what
you're supportive role
and you know when you said that that
when wives weren't interested that it
really created a very different scene
for the president you think it would be
harder to be president if you didn't
have a supportive spouse yes I do
sure yes I do I think you need a place
to come home to and somebody to bounce
ideas off or somebody who just say
what's happened or not happened we had
one bachelor and it was prisoned oddly
enough his name was Stratton Samuel
Stratton I believe he was a bachelor
mm-hmm
but I think all the others have been
married mmm and wives were very
supportive mm-hmm and and when you say
you need people to bounce ideas off of
did you feel that you heard a great deal
of what was going on even during the
times when oh yes I mean I remember
Barbara Bush talking about pillow talk
Thursday yes you remember that from the
movie oh yes it is true sure and then if
if something happens or something is
going to be decided or something then
you say well what happened how did that
go or what did this happen and maybe two
weeks later it could be two months later
and so you do sort of stay as an ongoing
part of it and you know in a sense
you're a confident in that you know a
lot of things that other people don't
know mm-hmm that are happening or about
themselves or about what's going to
happen or about right that would
sometimes be worrisome yeah you you know
you you know a lot of things you've
never tell mm-hmm and I'm sure that's
true of everybody
we'll change you're asking me if there
would be a woman president of MIT or not
would there but when there is well I
don't think I'll live to see it but I I
think that it could happen I think that
women have done very well in many places
but I think that top brass ring alludes
a lot of them and it's close but it's
not quite there yet for this institution
because that's for this institution and
it's not necessarily true of others I
think a woman is now president of Duke
and that's after all a big University
and it's a big change it's it's got a
lot to be coped with given I'm going to
switch topics a bit and given the fact
that women are thinking so much more
about their own careers what do you
think is going to be the role of
volunteerism activities like the Women's
League at an institution like this well
it's had a rough 10 years there's no
doubt about it because in the mid 70s
late 70s early 80s women that went to
work back to work our women finished
graduate or school or something like
that and went to work and they're still
working and they're teaching or they're
researching or they're professionals of
some sort and given the economy and the
interests of women doing what they're
doing I can't see that it would change I
think women are going to continue to
push and try to get there do you think
that's a loss for a place like MIT
you know oh no not really but the the
days of coming in forties or just to
play bridge or more casual things there
aren't as many people doing that now
mm-hmm as there used to be mm-hmm don't
think and and what about the the
transitions in your life out of the
presidency was that a major change for
you
well when Jim Killian retired Howard
became chairman and of course we just
moved down the street as it were and so
we had somewhat the same function and in
that we lived in the can't on the campus
we entertained the corporation or a
corporation meetings the Chairman by and
large over the years has been the chief
fundraiser for the Institute so we did a
lot of that sort of thing a lot of
travel a lot of alumni things and so it
didn't it wasn't a traumatic breaking
the nature no it wasn't like you had to
start all over again someplace I was
still here mm-hmm
for a long time really so the transition
was was not difficult no nature not at
all for us what what are some of your
recollections of the of the Killians
there well Liz is gone so mean course
you can't interview her right yeah when
we first came here he was president
that's true
Liz had had serious health problems as
you know she was an absolutely
remarkable I would ask her things about
people do you know so-and-so or what
happened in nineteen something
and she look at me and frequently she
maybe didn't know and the next time I'd
see her she'd say you know you asked me
about something and then she give me the
complete line of it but for all those
series of strokes that she had she
really her mind was wonderful she just
worked through whatever the problem was
and she really she was a remarkable
person she really was she she really was
mm-hmm
and Jim well Jim was you know to me for
me I would say no always friendly but he
was kind of austere and he was a
reserved to me more of a reserved kind
of a person and he played his cards
close to the chest chest as the
expression goes he was not open and
outgoing and you know very he was he was
a quiet mm-hmm
person mm-hmm and and when Howard was
president what about your did you have
to take precautions about the kinds of
relationships you had with other people
who are part of the administration so
that you wouldn't be you know accused of
favoritism or anything like that did
those issues come up I don't know not
really I I think that that it is true
you know many many people and you meet
many people and if anything you do
somehow feel it's various times
not exactly loneliness but that you have
a certain superficial relationship a
very surface social kind of
not not great depth mm-hmm and I think
that's true in a corporate situation I
know it is it's lonely at the top for
people always has been mm-hmm
and it to a certain extent it's probably
you can't inactive deep friends yes it's
because it's a little harder because of
the time constraints and also because of
what yours right it's it's different yes
your role but we all had our own friends
and I think in my case I had friends
outside of the Institute mm-hmm mm-hmm
we met different places or where we
lived before we were in that job right I
still have friends from way back then
uh-huh so the older we get as you know
the more you treasure your friends right
long-standing right and that's true
well how did how do your how does your
family does your family now sit and
reflect on those years from signo six to
seventy one subject rarely comes up
really no no not at all and what about
between you and Howard is that something
that you talk about very much er no not
really
no I wouldn't say so life has moved you
didn't we just you go with the flow of
your life and no we don't talk about it
a lot no but you remember it certainly
yes don't sure it was a good feeling
right yeah right
is it kind of everything based around at
the community of MIT at that time yes
your life is very much revolves around
living here being a part of it going to
things it seems you know over the years
for a while you know we went to an awful
lot of funerals which is somewhat a bit
bizarre to say but it's true it's part
of your own goals you know these people
you like them you worked with them are
you socialized with your party your life
did you think of it as your career I
mean if somebody said to you you know if
you were sitting this is a question that
comes up for women all the time if
somebody turns to you and says and what
do you do yes well the word career has
always kind of bothered me because to me
career is is a very structured thing you
know you're a psychologist or you're an
accountant or you're a lawyer
that's your career well I wasn't any of
those things and so I never thought of
it as a career per se no no I did intend
of people said and what do you do
looked at you with piercing eyes what
did I say well probably something rather
not too too bright really well are there
other things Betty that you would like
to that you'd like to talk about that we
have overlooked well I can't think of
much except to say that I think MIT is a
very special place and I think I'm very
very lucky to have been here all these
years
mm-hmm appreciate it had you known about
MIT when you were growing up well I knew
the name I grew up in the Midwest and
then I went to a little school in Ohio
and I did know it yes but I
my father wasn't an engineer II I I
wasn't really tuned into it as such no
not really
so what's a whole new word was a whole
new world yeah for you you know meeting
all these the techies are the yeah the
Nerds
was the other nerds it was all new yes
I'm pretty wonderful uh-huh well there
are other things Chris that you think
about is there anything else you'd want
to say about about women and the
changing roles of women maybe that we
haven't touched on not really no I don't
think so I'm pretty good women's libber
so are you
but right I'm not out waving the flag I
I think it has to be slow and gradual
and as those things flow and bright were
you I think there are peaks and valleys
I think things go along and and women
take a big step forward and then I think
things kind of coast and it's not all
it's not all gonna happen overnight
means you're always interested and there
always will be some differences you know
somebody has to take time out and have
the next generation and so on it makes a
difference
I think doser Nick's mom do you think
let me ask another question in relation
to women's roles do you think that
somebody in a role as president can
devote as much time as they would like
to her as much time as a spouse would
like them to to being a parent for
example
well I think you always look back over
parenting and think you could have done
better might have done things some
differently I know I would have if I
could do some things over again but you
can't so you know you did what was best
at the time I don't I don't think my
children suffered terribly no because
their father wasn't home for dinner
every night or some such thing No